what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight prediction video for those of you
that entered the new giveaway make sure
you stay until the end of the video
because I will announce the name of the
first-place winner but in today's video
I kind of want to talk about bran Stark
and his role during the endgame I should
put a disclaimer before I say any of
this because I have no idea how likely
any of this is to happen but in my
opinion it is very possible like most
things in this story everyone should
know that the knight King brought down
the wall with Viserion and now him and
his entire army are marching south of
the wall and as of right now there is no
one in front of them to stop them yet
John and Daenerys are heading to white
Harbor then they will travel north to
Winterfell and by the time they get
there the night king should be awfully
close to Winterfell as well it's looking
like we could see the war against the
night King very soon and now that he has
a dragon of his own in John and Daenerys
didn't get the help from Cersei that
they wanted they're gonna need to find
some help from another source and this
is where brain star could come into play
brain store has the power to look back
in time and see things that no one else
has seen except for the people who were
there when it happened there was a very
good example of this during the season 7
finale when Brian Stark went back and
saw the secret wedding between Rhaegar
and Lyanna brain is really starting to
harness his powers now that he is
becoming more and more experienced as
the new three-eyed raven but he still
can't do any and everything on his own
Samwell Tarly was actually the one who
told Brandon to go back in time and look
and see if he could see anything with
Rhaegar and Lyanna because Sam had
learned about this - when Gilly found
the old record of the wedding kept by a
maester and when I saw this scene this
is when I started to think to myself
what else could bran Stark go back in
time and see that could actually help
them during the Great War bran Stark is
arguably one of the most important
characters but he didn't do a whole lot
during season 7 he did help expose
Littlefinger and he did see the wedding
between Rhaegar and Lyanna which is
definitely important in terms of the
overall story but I still feel like bran
has an ace or two up his sleeve that we
have yet to see and it has to be
something big something that can help
defeat the night king bran already went
back and saw how the night king was
created so I don't see why he can't go
back and possibly see how he can be
defeated now I know some people say that
answer is simple most people may assume
that the night king can be killed by
valerian steel and dragon glass just
like any other white Walker but I never
believed that was the case I think it's
gonna take something much more than that
to kill the night king he is the most
powerful of all the White Walkers so I
highly doubt he can be killed by the
same weapons as them but this is just my
opinion some of you that are watching
this right now should already know what
I believe will need to be done to stop
the night King I think it's gonna take
something special something along the
lines of a dragon or a sword called
light bringer Azure HEIs famous burning
sword that he used and the darkness
thousands of years ago the whole azure
Ahai prophecy could be seen as just a
legend some kind of story passed down
generation to generation that isn't
necessarily true but then again if it's
true then history may repeat itself like
many things I've done in this story
before
Melisandre certainly believes it to be
true and she's going to volantis but
then she's coming back so she will most
likely have a role to play in this also
but this is where Brian star could help
out and maybe even Sam or Gilly at the
beginning of season seven there was
potentially a very important yet brief
scene that may have been foreshadowing
the end of this series while Sam and
Gilly were still at the Citadel Sam was
reading up on dragon class on
Dragonstone but Gilly also grabbed the
book to read and the camera specifically
showed the cover of the book she was
reading and the cover said the long
night but there wasn't anything
mentioned about what she actually read
during that time period before season 7
premiere dates bo actually released
several photos from several different
scenes and one of the photos was of
Gilly reading the book about the long
night and when you zoom in and look at
the page she is reading it's actually a
page from the world of Ice and Fire book
and guess what it's about it's about
azor Ahai none of this was ever
mentioned but they may be keeping this
in their back pocket for season eight
now that Sam and Gilly are in Winterfell
when Sam is already bonding and figuring
things out what Brian they may reference
what was in this book about the long
night Sam's main purpose of going to the
Citadel was so he could help Jon against
the night king when the time came well
time has almost stopped the night king
is heading their way
and jon is heading their way now is the
time for Sam to help Jon and in my
opinion they may have to use something
from the
about the long night considering this is
exactly what they are about to deal with
we could possibly get a scene of Sam or
Gilly mentioning to Brian what was in
the book or they might even bring it up
to John they could tell them about Ozora
hi and now he was the one to use the
burning sword to end the darkness and
this could be when Sam and Brian put
their knowledge or power so to speak
together once again just like they did
to find out the truth about Jon Snow's
parents I'm pretty sure we're gonna get
a scene with John Sam and bran all
talking together brain is going to tell
John that he saw the night King take
down the wall and that he's coming their
way and this is when Sam can talk about
everything that they read about how to
survive the long night now I realize
this might be a bit of a stretch but
brain could look into the past and see
exactly what azor Ahai did and brain can
pass this knowledge on to Jon and this
can be the beginning of John fulfilling
the azure Ahai prophecy and ending the
long night I strongly believe Sam and
brain still have big roles to play
regarding the end game of this series in
considering Melisandre is coming back to
Westeros she could end up being the
niece Aneesa the one who will bare her
breasts for azor Ahai to plunge his
sword into to create light bringer
Daenerys could also be nice' niece as
well because there is evidence to
support both theories actually and there
is even a theory that says Daenerys
could be a Zora hi or the princess that
was promised but regardless of how this
plays out I believe that will come to
fruition in some form or fashion but
these are all just my opinions and you
can certainly disagree with me just let
me know what you think about all this I
would like to hear your thoughts about
this topic now let's get on to the first
Prize winner of the new giveaway in case
you don't know I'm giving away all seven
seasons of Game of Thrones
there will be seven different winners in
each winner will get to pick what season
they want out of the seven seasons that
I have I apologize if I mispronounced
your name but the first winner is bond
theory arson congratulations all you
need to do is private message me on
youtube or you can send me an email that
way I can give your prize to you as soon
as possible just let me know what season
you want I want to thank everybody for
participating and everyone else for
watching today's video
I really appreciate that and I also want
to thank those of you who support this
channel on patreon I hope you all have a
great day I will see you in the next one
by
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]